[Musik]
der goldene stadt am pazifik
lebensfreude lockerheit laissez faire
das war einmal
heute trifft es für die traumfabrik
hollywood ist die korona pandemie ein
albtraum kalifornien los angeles
hollywood in diesem frühjahr wie im
winterschlaf millionen menschen am
abgrund
es ist das erste mal seit der korona
krise dass eric mosley wieder auf dem
hollywood boulevard kommt prachtstraße
in los angeles das herz von hollywood
eric kann es nicht fassen wo sonst
filmschaffende und touristen über die
sterne des walk of fame flanieren heute
stille und leere
ich komme aus der u-bahn in ein geister
viertel
ich hoffe das ist nicht das neue
normalen hollywood kalifornien
hier wo auch die oscars verliehen werden
hat eric als kellner bei großen
filmpremieren gearbeitet hoch gekämpft
hat er sich aus der obdachlosigkeit
mitten hinein ins getümmel der promis
und stars
das war vielleicht das letzte mal für
mich als kellner hier in hollywood
ich muss nun abwarten wie jeder der
gebannt auf arbeit hofft hollywood ist
wie jeder andere jobs entlässt ich und
du bist raus
nach 20 jahren mit drogen einem leben
auf der straße sah eric seine chance in
hollywood gekommen nun sieht er sie
schwinden
surfin usa ist an den meisten
kalifornischen stränden immer noch
verboten nachdem einige ungeduldige
counties ihre strände wieder geöffnet
hatten machte der gouverneur sie
kurzerhand wieder dicht aus sorge vor
dem virus
die rettungsschwimmer sind dennoch nicht
arbeitslos sie bewachen weiter den
strand damit auch die unbelehrbaren
sicher sind mir gefällt es besser wenn
es voll ist dann vergeht die zeit
schneller ich wünschte mir jeder tag
wäre sonnig und voll das ist das beste
in der rettungsschwimmer sitzt die
polizei patroulliert die strände
verscheucht die die nicht hier sein
dürften die strafen gehen hoch bis zu
1000 dollar
einige hat die polizei gar schon
verhaftet aber der strand ist
geschlossen seit märz sind die strände
dicht ende der sperrung offen nicht
allen gefällt das die ärzte raten und
vitamin d zu tanken und uns zu bewähren
wir beachten alle pur ohne regeln und
trotzdem sollen wir gehen früh schränkte
der gouverneur in kalifornien das
öffentliche leben ein vergleichsweise
niedrig die zahl der infizierten und
toten in los angeles starben bislang
rund 1000 menschen am virus in new york
city rund 13.000 doch wirtschaftlich
trifft es kalifornien habt knapp vier
millionen menschen hat die korona
pandemie hier bereits arbeitslos gemacht
43 prozent der california könnte ihren
job verlieren
eine soziale krise wird dem virus folgen
und den gegensatz von arm und reich
weiter verschärfen
zurück bei kellner eric er hat seinen
job verloren doch er sorgt sich um die
ganz unten
downtown los angeles eines der größten
obdachlosenlager des landes skid row 150
tausend obdachlose gibt es in
kalifornien mehr als irgendwo sonst in
den usa knapp 60.000 hat allein eric
befürchtet mit corona könnten es bald
noch mehr sein die die heute schon auf
der straße leben will er aufklären über
masken händewaschen und social systems
inc
ich kann meine maske nicht will was
keine maske social distance lng hier
wird es kaum eingehalten eric meint es
ist nicht nur das unwissen der
obdachlosen oft fehlt ihnen
selbstachtung
ich denke sie halten sich für
überflüssig so leben sie einfach weiter
ihr leben und dazu gehört nun mal nicht
sich vor dem corona virus zu schützen
eric will ihr ansprechpartner sein
schließlich war er mal einer von ihnen
ich habe selbst 20 jahre auf der straße
gelebt und war cracks süchtig ich bin
auch nichts besseres
heute will er helfen auch wenn er sich
dabei mit dem virus infizieren könnte
wenn ich zu hause blieb wo es sicher ist
wofür wäre ich dann gut selbst wenn ich
dafür sterben müsste weil das hier meine
mission auf erden ist dann ist es das
was ich tun
[Musik]
seit vier jahren ist eric selber nicht
mehr obdachlos doch auch zu hause
beschäftigt die skid row ihn weiter film
clips und fotos schneidet er zusammen
für all die die sich interessieren
sein reich eine sozialwohnung ein zimmer
mit improvisierter küchenzeile der staat
zahlt zur miete was dazu klein doch er
liebt sein zuhause jetzt erst recht wo
corona droht ihm alles zu nehmen
während dieser pandemie bin ich manchmal
hier und merke ich beklage mich gar
nicht mehr da sie ist es das ist gerade
wie eine villa für mich 20 jahre auf der
straße nun ein ort wo ich hin kann
großartig es eric befürchtet dass corona
virus wird nach der gesundheitskrise
eine soziale krise bringen so viele
menschen ohne job so viele menschen die
abrutschen werden das bisschen was er
sich erkämpft hat sieht er in gefahr es
wird eine art verdrängungswettbewerb
geben sagt er
meine größte sorge ist meine wohnung die
leute von dagegen über und von nebenan
werden nach bezuschussten wohnungen wie
meiner suchen die werden stark gefragt
sein ich muss aufpassen dass ich meine
behalten kann
bislang hat monika einmal die woche
meditiert nun in der korona krise tut
sie es täglich
mit dem yoga lehrer im uhr beginnt sie
jeden tag sie braucht das sagt sie um
ruhig zu bleiben und mitfühlend in
dieser zeit der krise
alles fragen was so fürchte ich mich
nicht so sehr typischer weise reagieren
menschen auf solch eine situation ja mit
angst die meditation hilft mir die angst
zu reduzieren er zu agieren als zu
reagieren sagt monika ist
kostümbildnerin sie hat die ganz großen
in hollywood angezogen brad pitt cate
blanchett nun ist auch sie arbeitslos
170000 andere die bislang für die
traumfabrik gearbeitet haben
es bleiben ihr ein paar kostüme in ihrer
garage
doch sie vermisst die stoffe und die
stars ihre spezialität historische
kostümfilme sie ahnt wenn irgendwann
wieder gefilmt wird das hollywood wird
ein anderes sein
wir gehen auf dieselben klos wir stehen
zusammen fürs essen an nutzen dasselbe
besteck ich denke die welt wird eine
ganz andere sein wenn wir wieder zurück
an unsere arbeit gehen wir werden
sicherlich schutzkleidung tragen müssen
monika mit gesichtsmasken um wenigstens
irgendwas zu tun und zu helfen ihre
gewerkschaft verteilt die masken dann an
das personal von krankenhäusern und
altenheimen
es zeigt dass die leute in unserer
gewerkschaft ihre kreativität auch für
etwas im moment ein wichtiges nutzen
können nämlich masken und schutzanzüge
zu machen für die die keine haben
das ist super wichtig wir spielen eine
große rolle dabei dass die menschen
sicher sehr monika ist vorbereitet immer
dabei eingepackt dann notfallrucksack
helm verbandszeug trockenfutter für
katastrophen wie waldbrände oder
erdbeben
sie hofft all das hilft auch sollte die
korona pandemie mal völlige isolierung
verlangen
monika unterstützt arbeitslose kollegen
mit kleinen aufträgen und mit besuchen
dem kostümbildner silas bringt sie eine
ladung vorhänge zum nähen
der freut sich jemanden zu sehen für
dieses jahr hatte er ein traumangebot
nun steht hollywood still
auch okay sagt sie las er will
stattdessen an sich arbeiten
ich bin ein sehr geduldiger ich setze
mein leben einfach in warteposition
ich bin nicht enttäuscht dass die dinge
nicht funktionieren wie geplant ich
mache aber keine pläne für die zukunft
das universum sagt wir brauchen eine
pause
ich nehme die chance an eine pause
einzulegen und auf mich zu schauen
monika zieht kraft aus diesen besuchen
sie jammert nicht sondern macht so fühle
ich mich als teil der lösung teil der
gegenseitigen hilfe statt zu hause zu
sitzen und dauernd fernsehen zuschauen
tue ich etwas was tatsächlich eine
wirkung hat auf das leben von anderen
das jobcenter von pasadena am rand von
los angeles
manchmal saßen hier 60 mann in der
hoffnung auf arbeit tagelöhner
undokumentierten migranten
doch lewis musste zu machen das center
ein gesundheitsrisiko in zeiten von
corona hieß es von den behörden und es
fehlt an jobs keiner stellt mehr ein
wir wissen dass viele der arbeiter sehr
zu kämpfen haben wegen des fehlenden
einkommens
sie müssen die miete bezahlen
lebensmittel und ihre rechnungen was sie
zuerst zahlen sind ihre rechnungen ich
weiß statt um jobs kümmert sich louis
nun um reis und bohnen er sammelt
spenden von den unternehmen die bislang
die tagelöhner angeheuert haben
dies ist gelebte solidarität senden die
botschaft auch wenn wir dichtmachen
mussten und keine arbeit verteilen
können wir lassen euch nicht allein
wir sind auch jetzt an eurer seite
abgefüllt in salza schälchen
desinfektionsmittel für die hände
dazu packt louis maske nein wenn er sich
zu den tagelöhnern draußen auf der
straße auf macht rund um das jobcenter
und vor baumärkten warten sie auf arbeit
migranten aus mexiko honduras guatemala
louis gibt ihnen tipps nur mit maske und
desinfektionsmittel habt ihr überhaupt
eine chance auf einen job
der gouverneur von kalifornien
verspricht auch undokumentierten
hilfsschiffs darauf vertrauen sie nicht
ohne krankenversicherung fürchten sie
das virus doch sie müssen arbeiten
es ist so hart aber wir müssen unsere
miete und essen bezahlen
es ist gerade sehr schwierig
wir müssen irgendwie durch stark sein
wir können nirgendwohin nach guatemala
zurück ist auch keine lösung
dieses problem ist ein weltweites
[Musik]
eric klettert hinauf in die hügel von
los angeles zum hollywood schriftzug
kurz hatte er zutritt zur glitzerwelt
jetzt hatte angst dass alles vorbei sein
könnte er gar wieder obdachlos wird also
meinen amerikanischen traum hat corona
zerstört ob er je wieder kommen wird ich
hoffe hollywood kommt zurück
corona hat auch die traumfabrik erreicht
und die die für sie arbeiten erika und
die krise beginnt erst
[Musik]